nobody here is getting out alive
I'm not sick I'm free
you're all prisoners just three little
cogs in a giant absurd machine
hey youtubers it's Charlie big stuff
there's a new trailer for Gotham
introducing some of the villains setting
the stage for court of Alice and yes
Gotham did confirm that it is doing the
court of the owls storyline from the
comics because TV shows tend to change
things what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
explain court of owls from the comics
then I'm gonna explain how the TV show
might change that story in light just a
little bit there's one really big
conceit of the storyline in the comics
that I don't think that the TV show is
gonna go with so just some quick
background the court of the alice is
like Batman's version of the Illuminati
secret shadow organization that they
retconned in the new 52 to have gone all
the way back through the history of
Gotham it was the story that kicked off
Batman's reboot in the new 52 probably
like one of the best possible things to
come out of the new 52 just in general I
know a lot of comic book fans have big
complaints about the new 52 but I do
feel like the court of the owls was one
of the best things to come out of it so
in the comics Bruce Wayne wanted to do
some good in Gotham announces this grand
plan to redesign it make it better so
shadow organization with their own ideas
about the future of Gotham rear their
heads they send trained assassins to try
it and either bring him into the fold or
take him down on the surface they're
presented as this typical evil
organization but then Bruce Wayne finds
that he has deep ties to them through
his family going back through the entire
history of Gotham oh my god my father
was connected to them what does this
mean about my identity what does this
say about the major events that shaped
my life so because this larger identity
crisis in this battle for who gets to
control the future of Gotham you know is
it going to be the more egalitarian
Bruce Wayne or is it going to be this
secret shadow organization that seems
super sinister now because a lot of you
might not have read the court of owls
storyline there's one part that I'm
gonna leave out there's a link in march
character there's like a big twist
behind his character I'm not going to
explain I don't think the TV show is
gonna do that part of the arc they're
gonna change that and they're gonna give
a lot of those things to the theo
galavan character he'll be the public
face of the court and his sister who is
tigress on the show she's gonna be a
little bit like one of the talents but I
don't think that we're gonna see
full-blown talons the talons are kind of
fun by themselves too that they have
like a form of immortality they used
through science if you saw the animated
movie Batman versus Robin they kind of
show it it's kind of true to the comics
but it gets way oversimplified they go
into much greater detail
the comic book essentially they're meant
to be unkillable soldiers in the front
of this owl imagery is that the natural
predator of the bat is the owl so you
know court of owls predatory for Batman
Bruce Wayne now the TV show isn't
completely centered on the Bruce Wayne
character and the way that the comic
books are so they're gonna broaden this
court of owls idea we're gonna see feel
here doing court of owls related things
with all of the characters not just the
Bruce Wayne character but the Bruce part
of the arc will be relatively true to
the comics in that he has big
revelations on the role that his family
has played in the shadow organization in
the big things that have happened across
Gotham's history that was the big theory
last year is that when he started to get
involved with the Wayne board he was
pushing into court ivalice
territory as in like a bunch of the
board members were on the court of owls
now I don't think it's gonna be that
literal but I do think there'll be like
one person from the court of owls on the
Wayne board and Thiel here will be like
their person on the ground they're also
introducing the silver st. cloud
character from the comics and they're
introducing her as part of Bruce's arc
so that's probably gonna tie in with
court eval stuff too she's another high
society character from the comics that
mostly gets tied up in a Hugo Strange
art going way way back so I think a good
analogy for her character will be kind
of like the Samantha vana fur character
from the animated Batman versa where
they put her in a relationship with
Bruce but she was also part of the court
of the owls now very clearly a young
girl isn't gonna be controlling the
court of Alice I think she's just gonna
have deep ties to them she's gonna be
Bruce's introduction to the court but
really at the end of the day this is
just a way for the TV show to deepen its
mythology in the best possible way I
feel like that's what Gotham needs to do
I mean it's fun to see Batman freaks of
the week but you can't build your
mythology if all the characters reset
every single episode like there's
something to be said for serializing
your season I feel like in the age of
Netflix and binge watching people are
just a little bit better at following
storylines like even if you pick up a
chokehold and you like you have no idea
what's going on with Gotham you'll pick
it up pretty fast so you guys let me
know in the comments which version of
the Court of owls storyline have you
read or seen like did you watch the
Batman verse 9 he did you read the
storyline in the comics both of those
are a little bit different but they do
deal with the court I wasn't really
happy with the way the animated movie
deleted the Lincoln March character but
but you get the idea like if you read
the comic book storyline you kind of
understand why they
want to do that because they wanted it
to be more about Robin trying to figure
out his identity rather than Bruce Wayne
figuring out his identity like they turn
quarter vowels into a Damian Wayne
storyline versus a Bruce Wayne storyline
I'm also kind of wondering if they're
gonna try and tie Barbara to the court
just because she's also high society
like she comes from money anybody that
comes from old money in Gotham has ties
to the court so what's gonna happen next
is is I need to do a vixen video I still
have a Doctor Who Q&A to do and he Rose
is starting tomorrow so I'll try and get
all that stuff out as fast as possible
I'm hoping for some new stuff from arrow
season 4 - so depending on when
everything drops I'll just I'll post all
those videos so a couple really cool
things coming the next day or two be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
if you guys didn't see I'm actually
doing a new round of the reverse flash
ring giveaway I just I posted a new
flash trailer video you can click here
to watch that learn all about that
giveaway and you can click here for my
Gotham season 2 episode 1 video if you
ever needed a reason to start watching
Gotham it's quarter Val's start right
now seriously thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you